over your past relationship did you
um
like what's helped you get through it
because I can't even imagine eight years
even even if you weren't emotionally
involved that's still a lot
um I think I've just
obviously where it was my decision there
wasn't particularly too much heartbreak
on my side which I'm not cold-hearted
I'm not just over like that like eight
years a long time
but
I think just trying to get out there be
myself again and be happy
what advice would you have for someone
that's going through a breakup
[Music]
if you don't feel like you can be
yourself in that relationship
however hard it is
saying no to that person you don't want
to be together you've got to do it for
your own like well-being because
again it's horrible to say but I'm
happier now yeah
no disrespect to her but I can't have
you now no me too yeah me too like I
understand it is hard to say like no you
don't be mean that
is freedom and a bit of like weight off
your shoulders like I said earlier off
your shoulders exactly the swag I don't
know I was in a very like
like very like he was jealous kind of
controlling you know that type of thing
and like just like I felt like I was a
like a kid getting like
how do I put it like let out like like
your parents like getting out of my
parents house because I was so tired of
like having to like answer to someone
all the time you know what I mean like
yeah that's
how I felt that I just couldn't be
myself anymore if we were still in the
relationship I wouldn't be here tonight
yeah or come on any of the other shows
because I just feel
I have to be there with her doing this
after that yeah because now I'm just
like a free man did you come to that
party I threw when I first got here nope
oh no it's funny because when did you
get here though because I joined
volleyball late November
well I got here October 15th okay or
20th like something like that and then
I threw that party for my birthday it
was like the fourth
no you weren't there I didn't know
anyone though so it was kind of like oh
my God there's so much going on yeah it
was also like when I started uni was I
was still with her so very much
I'd be on campus do my lectures do my
volleyball go home to her whereas now
I'm more just out there myself being
around other people do you guys have
intertwined friend groups because I
didn't with my ex-boyfriend and that
made it a lot easier but I can't you
guys dated for eight years so is it hard
with the mutual friends
is 50 50 like when she was at Uni all
the friends she made
I became friends with
and like
I know she has spoken to them about the
breakup
I'm surprised they haven't messaged me
about it at all I would like to know
what she said to them and her side of it
because obviously I've said to my
friends and my family my side of it yeah
but there's always two stories two sides
of things that's always going to be yeah
perceived differently yeah
but
um no we both were also both
involleyball in England there's a lot of
people we both know oh she plays
volleyball yeah yeah where does she play
uh she doesn't actually play at the
moment she only coaches at the moment oh
wow
um at the guys game yesterday in
Kingston as a fella who came across to
me said hi we were good friends together
in Southampton and is our house fittings
house things how she and I was like
we've broken up and it's like oh damn we
went we went out a lot together
all of us well so it's really awkward
when people ask you yeah it is awkward
back like
when I first because Lee an eight-year
relationship it wasn't something I
wanted to talk to my family about like
on the phone or texting them so I did
wait till I went down there again to
talk to them about it they picked me up
from the coach station or in the car
they're like Oh Sheila I was like it was
okay it was like and we sat down for
lunch or breakfast and it's like
actually we have broken up this happened
yeah
is
is tough just like talking through with
everyone yeah and I went out with my
friends that night
so I'm out with a mate told him about it
we picked someone up in the car told him
about it got to where I go until
everyone else about it's like guys can
we just talk like this once and once
only and so everyone at once not
everyone individually as we see them
girls
talk more
so I what I've noticed like I feel like
girls when we go through a breakup like
we'll tell our whole friend group we're
gonna talk [ __ ] obviously like
and she doesn't no that's part of the
issue
oh okay well it's really good she's not
talking [ __ ] around
yeah that's true yeah
I see ways you can manipulator that I've
done it wrong but
if she does she does at the end of the
day I know why I've done what I've done
yeah
and
if anyone wants to question me on it
come question me on it yeah I'll tell
you straight how it was from my side
yeah yeah
okay wait I'm gonna look for the chat
um someone says
let's see
Pearl throwing parties and we weren't
invited on
subscribing
guys guys I threw one party when I got
here
I don't even drink and all these people
showed up I didn't even know it was like
it wasn't
oh my gosh
and then
I
well and I'm not gonna read that one
my advice is to go home and cry that
[ __ ] out breakups hurt you gotta work
through it hitting the gym worked for me
as well that's what meet us the
stallions Wow have you are you after
breakup do you go to the gym are you
like a on a
you don't tell me but I haven't been to
the gym all year
um just yeah I do want to get back in
the gym though before I moved to London
I was in the gym an unhealthy amount
yeah I moved to London like life's busy
yeah every single time for it but I do
want to get back in there
I enjoy training
I'll get rid of the dad bod
um I think you need different friend
groups you need a break from each other
at first do you think that's true
yeah we definitely like yes I walk
within the house at the moment there
needs to be a break
yeah
and then
I don't know how did you come back
together after a break
how do you
um
oh my God I can't even imagine living
with someone still dating like I'm
trying to wrap my head around that
yeah that's I don't even know what if
you like dated someone new like well
like because if a guy told me he still
lived with his ex I would be like oh God
have you told girls that yeah yeah do
they care
uh no they understand oh okay I've been
here
I think it's just maturity
that the guys I've been talking to yeah
there is one who I've spoken to she's
been in a similar situation where she's
been in a long-term relationship
she's had issues they've broken up
and like you know it's not a clean snap
like that when you've been in a
long-term relationship there is stuff
you share yeah and then
yeah just people understand yeah if
you're just truthful and honest people
understand
oh my gosh I can't even
I was I was like you see my face when
you told me that yeah
gosh
um
anything else in the chat
that it's a grieving process
sleeping around is bad for society and
it has resulted in the decline of
marriage
um increase in bastard kit oh my gosh
never mind
do you no sex until marriage will
alleviate a lot of confusion what do you
think about that
I don't get how people can't have sex
before marriage
I used to want to when I was younger
I like wanted to
I wish I did actually
yeah more of the sex is crap how would I
know if I'd never had sex with anyone
else
like you have nothing to compare it to
you know yeah but just because you've
got nothing to compare it to doesn't
mean it
just still wouldn't
feel right yeah
and like it's a very intimate process
yeah what if you go through
five six years together you get married
you live together and it just doesn't
feel right having sex like something
just isn't there
then what
something just doesn't there yeah I feel
like I would just like deal with it and
focus on other things
okay I just for me I don't think that's
like the most important thing in a
relationship like I values and like you
know that that sort of thing I think is
more important than like sex because I
feel like sex can be learned like you
can figure that out
then how is it land
like you learn with each other right
like
yeah yes yeah